Patch adams? No. It might be
the worst movie ever made. No,
it'd be the worst. I, it's probably
right up there with a Travolta God movie,
but I have,
oh my God,
I want to see that Travolta guy today
on the elliptical machine, fucking city.
Every second he says, fuck every
three words and you're like, oh John,
you look at you this fucking
city fucking logo look so bad.
I love that though. There is
something that I like. Ah,
I just like love the John.
There's something I like love
about a man so deeply out of touch.
I mean that's the thing is like, yeah,
look it up. Fucking thumbs fucking up.
Me and my wife's Jewish,
just Sarah Palin.
I love this fucking city boy.
The sexual chemistry between
them is palpable. Probably real.
Super Rich.
You were talking about at the beginning
of like like cults and I'm like,
I'm thinking about,
I'm thinking about Tom
Cruise and Scientology.
There is a man using every ounce of what
Scientology is offering to make himself
the best available man that he's capable
of being. Then you've got Travolta.
You know what I mean?
Like you've got two versions of like,
like Amanda is becoming slightly
out of touch with what he, you know,
Eh,
look at my fucking wig bank.
It's a good way. How amazing our wigs
these days. He's got great lakes.
That's a fucking incredible wig.
Thinning just a little bit upfront.
You would think that's his hair. He's
living the dream. It's incredible.
He's living the goddamn dream.
Uh,
you okay with time we could wrap this up
or whatever. Yeah. I'm 33 30. Yeah, we're,
what does that send the Shapiro on the
Oj thing? Oh yeah, that was, I saw him.
That's amazing. That little,
that Little Chin is that his,
he wore a little chin. He
got like a little Chin Yamaka
there. It's unbelievable.
I remember seeing him at
an award ceremony that,
and then that when he had that
Little Chin thing and I was like,
did he put that on after the thing? I
met him when his wife was on fear factor.
Really? Yeah. Kelly Preston was
on fear. She was on fear factor.
Celebrity fear factor. David Hasselhoff.
Kelly. Wow. Preston, how were they?
She was really nice.
She was super friendly,
but I felt like I felt
like they recruited people.
Yes,
they were there.
Scientology was sort of a stigmatized,
it was,
there was a lot of people that
were joining it. What is going on?
There is a black cat.
I love it.
That hair is so crazy fake looking.
That's like that magnetic
man that you could like move.
The magnets are on the Korean hair. Like
who's fucking hair? It looks like that.
That's crazy man. That's, I mean
the color, everything is wrong. Uh,
that's madness. Um, but
yeah, she was super friendly.
She was like really down to earth.
Super Normal and friendly and she's like,
these tranches are great.
You know,
if you eat enough and you want to come
and hang out later, we can eat more. True.
Yes. We could maximize eating. Sure.
Angela's and you can join. You can join.
We can let me get your phone number.
I'd like to have some eaters.
Yeah, I remember watching that, that go
and clear the documentary and being like,
Oh, I'm not scared. Like
they're not coming for me. Like,
Miscavige is not coming from me.
He's coming for like the people
under him who he sees as a threat.
Like I don't think he sees us as a threat.
Like I don't think he gives
a fuck us being like, ah,
I don't know about Scientology. He
shields himself from anything like this.
Any kind of criticism and,
but I do tell you that I had Miscavige
has dad on. Really? Yeah. Oh right.
Cause he's the, he's, he's, he
left. Yeah, he fucking escape.
But that's what I'm saying.
And like if I'm miss just dad,
I'm scared cause he's like Miscavige
just like my dad is a threat to me.
Like you and I talking about Scientology,
I don't think miss [inaudible] she gives
a fuck. It was a weird conversation.
What was he like?
Well he's sad is like,
he lost his whole life to this
nonsense and his son's gone.
Like he can't,
his son won't contact him.
It was his idea to get
the family and decided,
oh so he's filled with the guilt of that.
Yeah, the sun rises through the ranks,
winds a running the whole fucking thing.
And that was sudden won't talk to them.
My favorite thing is Miscavige
and Tom Cruise shaking hands. Yes,
it's the best. It's like this.
It's this. It's this tiny,
yes men.
Miscavige is trumping him where you can,
you can see Tom cruise trying to pull
his hand away and Miscavige is like,
I will not relent, I will not release.
And you can see Tom, Chris bean,
like this tiny or man than me has an
even higher level of Alpha in this than I
can and I will and I will,
I will relent. Well the,
the real threat to them as Leah Remini,
Leah Remini,
he's done like she is.
You could see him trying to
pull the fucking salute, salute,
salute and then hand can see Tom cruise
like trying to pull his hand away and
Miss [inaudible] won't let it go.
It's really fantastic.
Yeah. Unrelenting. You can
see he's trying to like,
you can see the hands trying to like
come loose any, won't let it happen.
He's like,
and it's like that Trump move.
My favorite thing is when they salute the,
the picture of Lrh.
They saluted a shitty science fiction
writer who was wearing that big dinner
plate around his neck and
they know and look at it.
Tom Cruise is not a tall man and
Miscavige is he towers over Tom Cruise.
Tom Cruise. Cowers over
this time. Sorry. Yes. Yeah.
Look at that fucking giant
gold medal. He Won. I know.
Being the most awesome as
person in university, but
again, I'm like, I don't know.
Did you see the resubmission
impossible. He's amazing. It's amazing.
He's a fucking fantastic acronym.
But I'm like, so on board.
I'm on board for the whole
thing. I'm like, listen man,
you know how hard it is to get a movie
made now to get anybody to pay attention.
Go learn the fucking flight helicopter.
Jump off a building and break your ankle.
Like fucking go for it,
man.
Well, you know as well as I do,
you've been around a lot of actors.
They're all fucking crazy.
But yeah, his crazy.
He's just a different kind of crazy,
but it's also a different kind of success.
Yeah.
But I'm like, he's a guy who I
feel like you would get like, like,
he's like, yeah, like whatever
I need to do. Like I will,
I will maximize myself. The gold
medal. It's fucking amazing. I love it.
I get some volume. Let me
hear some of this. Right.
I take this as a halfback,
some inside joke. That's like a good
insight. So I tagged you. Yeah, for sure.
I will continue on my way.
Okay.
These are the times now people,
okay.
These are the times we will all remember.
Isn't that the song? Were you there?
What did you do?
I think you know that I am there for you.
Hmm.
And I do care so very, very, very much.
That's why he's the best actor ever.
Yeah. Full of Shit right there.
Believe it or do you
think he's full of Shit?
I feel like he's on the
verge of fucking tears,
but he, he's full of Shit for
sure. With everything he does.
I don't think there's a moment in his
life where he's not full of shit. Right.
But he's believes it's so
deeply. Look at this. The salute.
Go back up, back up a little bit. I need
to see that again. Watch this dweller.
Right.
Well
if you know anything
bout that guy l Ron Hubbard
was a fucking maniac.
Did you read going clear or did
you just see the danger side?
Documentary book is fucking fantastic.
The book is,
he was fucking Shit House rat.
Crazy. Yeah. Crazy on a boat. Uh,
just he was out of his fucking mind.
Yeah. Himself. A bunch of metals, right?
Have you seen that? There's
a, there's a podcast called,
you must remember this and it's like
all about old Hollywood and it somehow
circumvents a little bit of like l Ron
Hubbard seen in like Pasadena with like
all these other like,
you know spiritualists futurists are like,
and it's like,
it's Cuckoos Ville.
They are like, they are,
they are cruising on their own fucking
agenda and it's kind of amazing.
But he's, yeah, it was, I can't, I
wish I had more information, but again,
my brain doesn't retain the stuff
I need to get into Scientology.
The books help if you just maximize
your EAD trons or whatever.
Fucking, did you ever do a
stress test? Do you ever go
one time I was filming a television show
in San Diego and we had downtime when
they were setting up a scene and uh,
we happen to be at a park where they had
one of those Scientology booths set up
and I went over there and uh, the guy
like put me through the whole thing.
I hold onto the, the cans and
they're connected to the wires,
but he was so unenthusiastic
he was just like,
he selling it at all. I was
like, he was bombed outside ties.
Anytime you got something,
I don't know.
Some of your past kiss the
feet and I don't know man.
I'm thinking I had no energy fall
who was hilarious. Worst salesman.
I think they just make them do it,
you know,
and some people don't want to
do it and next thing you know,
they've got a fucking conference tables
set up in a park and a stack of books
and they're going nowhere in Clearwater
join. Didn't no where near Clearwater.
They were on the other coast.
I got to get to the fucking east coast.